what do you think Company Number Four
will be you think there will be a
company number there's a lot to do in
Company Number two I'm just like I'm
talking about company number three now
did none of that Tech exists yet there's
a lot to do in company number two
company number two is going to be the
great struggle of the next six years and
if the next six years how centralized is
compute going to be the less centralized
compute is going to be the better of a
chance we all have so you're bearing the
you're like a flag bearer for open
source distributed decentralization of
uh compute we have to we have to or they
will just completely dominate us I
showed a picture on stream of a man
in a chicken farm ever seen one of those
like factory farm chicken farms why does
he dominate all the chickens
why does he smarter he's smarter right
some people some people on Twitch were
like he's bigger than the chickens yeah
and now here's a man in a cow Farm right
so it has nothing to do with their size
and everything to do with their
intelligence and if one Central
organization has all the intelligence
you'll be the chickens and they'll be
the chicken man
but if we all have the intelligence
where all the chickens
we're not all the man or all the
chickens when there's been a chicken man
there's no chicken man or just chickens
in Miami he was having a good life man
I'm sure he was I'm sure he was